this is one of 10 chess moves you have
to play before you die once a pawn has
struggled across seven ranks of a
war-torn chessboard it receives a
well-earned honor promotion to any chess
piece of its choosing barring the king
while one can choose a knight bishop or
Rook for promotion one almost always
chooses to promote to a queen
still there are special cases like the
famous savedra study where one promotes
to a rook to avoid stalemate
here is an incredible example from the
wildly popular samairina of a winning
under promotion opportunity you just
have to remember to hold alt to turn off
auto Queen and I'm almost hoping for him
to take the queen and at this point my
heart was in my mouth I was like oh my
God oh my God and then
I push the pawn
oh what we
going on